oh boy ten girls wouldn't trade it for
the world the loud house is definitely
one of the most popular cartoons around
but did you know that even the loud
house features jokes that were only
meant for adults one of Lin's jokes is
definitely our favorite give this video
a thumbs up and don't forget to
subscribe to our Channel now let's check
out 5 funniest adult jokes in the loud
house kids didn't understand hidden
cameras Lisa loud is by far one of the
strangest characters on the show she
might be only four years old but she's
definitely a complete genius but even
Lisa makes mistakes or we sometimes
think that she pretends to make them
there are a couple of moments on the
show that made the adults giggle
remember the walk and loud episode Lisa
accidentally reveals she's installed
cameras in the bathroom as the kids try
to make the house more secure but that
security mister had nothing to do with
the actual storyline after being
confronted on it by Lincoln Lisa just
gives a creepy smile and says that no
she didn't actually install cameras
cameras in a bathroom might seem like no
big deal to the kids but adults will
probably laugh out loud at this scene
and of course they will also be grossed
out because let's be honest Lisa can be
really weird sometimes and installing
cameras in the bathroom never ends well
in real life in the same episode she
also keeps asking her sisters for a
stool sample and even gives her mom a
pat-down that's dangerous that close to
her rear area after she's done she says
she'll still need a stool sample from
someone but she never really discloses
what she needs it for we're sure many
adults would definitely get a kick out
of Lisa strange jokes kicks a plus in
making the case we discovered that
Lincoln is the only member of the loud
family that hasn't won a trophy must be
pretty hard for Lincoln to grow up in a
family with such overachievers and we
bet that there are many kids out there
that can relate but we all know that the
loud family has one overachiever who
really tries to turn everything into a
competition and she never gives up
it's Lynn the only one in the family was
obsessed with sports LAN is known to be
the most competitive out of all and her
award in the families trophy case proves
that in the scene where Lincoln talks
about the girls trophies we also see
Lynn soccer trophies such as the
number-one trophy and the one shaped
like a ball with the word perfect
underneath
at the top you can also see an award
with kicks a plus of course this award
could mean two things
it suggests that Lin is really good at
kicks and got an a-plus for it but it
could also mean something completely
different and let's be honest if there's
anyone out there who knows how to kick
some butt
it's definitely Lin did you get the
double meaning of Lin's award make sure
to let us know in the comments Clyde's
nose bleeds every loud house fan knows
about Clyde's somewhat unhealthy
obsession with a 17 year old lorry the
oldest of the eleven loud siblings the
two have an interesting relationship
that mainly involves Clyde not being
able to speak much whenever Laurie's
around we seemed talking about her
drooling over her and even appreciating
her tooth but there's a running gag on
the show that will only make sense to
adults there are several scenes from the
show where client gets a nosebleed when
Laurie speaks to him sure it looks kind
of cute right a little kid having a
crush on someone much older and getting
nosebleeds because he gets so stressed
out and emotional when every Caesar but
there might just be a deeper meaning
behind these nosebleeds and we bet only
adults were able to make this connection
in Japanese media I know sleep is often
a sign of a character getting just a
little bit too excited in a way no child
plods it should be if you're an anime
fan you know exactly what we're talking
about but what are nosebleeds like that
doing and one of Nickelodeon's most
popular cartoons seems like the loud
house is taking it too far but wait
until you hear what happened when Laurie
actually did give Clyde a chance well
sort of Tunnel of Love a fair to
remember is an episode that's probably
Clyde's favorite Laurie wants to make
Bobby feel jealous because she's jealous
he's spending more time with Lincoln
Lydia's the per the plot alone is
definitely something a lot of adults
have gone through won't we it gets even
better this is also where you can find
one of many Clyde's nosebleeds we
mentioned earlier so in order to make
Bobby jealous for bringing Lincoln to
the fair Laurie also invited Clyde of
course he was so excited she pretty much
had to put on fake glasses on him and
drag his lifeless body on all rides but
the entire episode was full of innuendo
kids definitely miss from Laurie asking
Bobby if he wants her to ride because
she makes him dizzy to the random
weird-looking corndog in the next clip
this episode really wasn't for kids and
of course then there's the part where
Laurie throws Clyde into the cotton
candy machine the funniest moment all
adults raise their eyebrows that
happened immediately after the seller
runs away laurie takes a piece of cotton
candy from Clyde's head when Bobby
suddenly
sir how come she's never eaten cotton
candy off his head if you're old enough
you probably understand what Bobbie
meant and if you're still a child we
hope you don't understand this hidden
innuendo a lack of balls one of the best
moments in the loud house happened in
the episode called space invader along
with being one of our favorite episodes
it also featured one of the funniest
adult jokes you'd never expect on a
children's show like this one later Lucy
have a fight and since they're both
sharing a room Lincoln invites Lin to
share a room with him instead of course
he realizes this this is a huge mistake
when Lin completely disrespect his
privacy if you're a huge loud house hand
you probably know that Lin is brutally
honest and she was definitely brutally
honest in this episode but that's
exactly why this next moment is our
favorite when Lin first arrives to
Lincoln's room she mentions there's a
severe lack of balls in there she gives
a small pause and says that there's a
good thing she brought her own then
Lincoln gives her one of the most tired
looks ever do you understand what linman
this joke was so inappropriate for kids
the small paws and Lincoln's look
actually got deleted from the UK version
of this episode to make it seem less of
an innuendo we have to say it's one of
our favorite adult moments in the entire
show
what's yours make sure to let us know in
the comments and that's it for our video
for more videos like this one check out
10 the loud house episodes that weren't
for kids see you next time
[Music]